would you say that uh because what
originally how much time are you facing
you said you gotta I'm 35 to life 35
lives cause I'm a two I'm a three
Striker and I've been busted for other
robberies as a kid I grew up without a
household you know so I've had to
survive
[Music]
what it doesn't matter that red thing
don't matter it just it just mutes out
of the headphones
hearing him so I was like I just wanted
to make sure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's fine so that red button only
mutes the headphones
does that make sense yeah because you
heard it in the headphones yeah you're
good you're good all right I'm sorry so
you were supposed to do 35 because for
people who don't know in Cali they had
the three strikes yeah yeah three strike
laws is that still is that still it is
when like let's say that
you gotta understand the law is like a
chain link fence you know it has many
different Loops directions and
connections and how it's bonded together
but when you're a DA and you really want
to prosecute some somebody
every single case log that has existed
for mankind is open to you you just got
to learn how to use it in a loophole you
know what I'm saying so let's say for
instance you're you've done
um you've been busted for charm
robberies and one sexual assault right
right
um
the law might say oh it's not all three
armed robberies so we can't strike them
out you know what I'm saying but the D.A
if they catch you for three sexual
assaults they'll find a way to be like
okay it's the exact same crime every
time he's a there's a problem let's
strike them out on those streets so it
just depends now how bad the prosecution
wants you and what kind of case they
want you know so at what point in time
did you find out because once you get
put in 35 to life you're pretty much
like this is my life
um so I got I went to trial I've always
went I've always gone to trial because I
have nothing to lose you know when when
you um have something to lose like you
tend to take a deal yeah but with me
they never offered me a date it was
always life life or 25 plus on to me
might as well be life you know what I'm
saying so um so I went to trial and um I
lost in trial in Pomona Court Superior
Court
um judge Tia Fisher found me guilty of
all my charges except from assault with
a deadly weapon the shooting I beat
um but five armed robberies are
convicted of so um when she went you
know they so you get let's say today is
your day to find out your verdict you
get found guilty right right boom knock
you out go back to court come back in
two months for sentencing at that point
within those two months the law well the
judge the D.A either has the opportunity
to go through your file and try and give
you some leniency or they just don't
give a [ __ ] and give you the max time
right so a lot of times it depends on
your crime the seriousness of it the
violence behind it and really how it
went down to get some kind of sympathy
you know what I'm saying so um fortunate
for me the lawyer that I was going with
at the time
um really pushed for the judge to open
on my file so two months after her
verdict
um she gave me she gave me 18 years with
the probability of parole you know what
I'm saying so my case I was supposed to
get 35 to life but the judge um
basically told me look laws are changing
I'm gonna end up bringing you back 10
years anyways and land you go yeah she
wasn't lying to be honest with you yeah
like I went up with the 18 years from
the 18 10 years to turn to 13 years from
13 turned to 10 because of Prop 47 was
changing so many laws right Jerry Brown
the original person that wrote The Three
strike law came back because I don't
know if you know but California prisons
were so overflooded that
Arnold Schwarzenegger signed a state of
emergency which meant that we're so
populated we could start renting prisons
in other states and taking them so they
rented I think three prisons in Arizona
one in Oklahoma two in Mississippi
that's that prison that prison for
profit [ __ ] yes sir all federal
judges own that [ __ ] so you know if all
federal judges own the prisons
on the canteens and everything that
[ __ ] generates money in it how are
they not going to create a keep you in
prison yeah it's a hustle so um I ended
up from Centinela I ended up to Arizona
and then I went all the way to
Mississippi tallahatchee and then I came
back yeah [ __ ] yeah well we're getting
caught up in [ __ ] you know you think
that that was kind of like because of
the three strike thing hell yeah yeah
because they were giving people to well
because that was like California
specifically yeah yeah only it's an
enhancement you know it's an enhancement
but with the three strike law came a
gang of different enhancements you know
it wasn't just strikes like it was let's
say you you've been to prison before
they were giving you two extra for that
Jesus let's say
um it was gang involved that's automatic
10 to 15 extra years so there was a lot
of dudes Upstate that that their crime
only carried three years but they were
doing 18 off of enhancements
not actual crimes you know saying that
crimes that she had done in the past
things that didn't weren't even
prevalent in what you're robusted for
right now you know what I'm saying so
um as the loss changed my day changed
and it got to a point where I had been
down so long like just kick them out so
I got like I think a 10-day notice
before I came home oh [ __ ] yeah you
didn't know you were just like hell no I
came home [ __ ] up like like honestly
um emotionally mentally I wasn't
prepared right you know I was wired a
certain way you gotta understand like I
took so much loss while I was busted as
far as heartbreak and heartache like I
suffered yeah all kinds of people that
emotionally I wasn't I wasn't confident
bro like I was you know my spirit was
broke to a certain extent like I know
flight or fly I know how to survived
right I knew how to be heartless and
take care of business in there but I
didn't know how to digest some
my care for the world my care for my
life you know what I'm saying I lost
some implication my family I lost a lot
of [ __ ] I lost a lot